Handling your own orthographic
camera is often necessary, but
there's quite a lot of fuss involved
with getting the aspect ratio right and
in positioning your world on the screen.
If you don't need to move your
camera around in your game world,
it's often easier to use
a viewport to manage your camera.
We've set up a little demo project
to show off the various viewports.
What we're doing is, we're drawing a
little checkerboard that's 16 units wide
by 9 units tall, which is intentionally
not the same size as the window we're
going to use to display this world.
So here in create we've made
an orthographic camera, and
the first viewport we're going to
explore is the ScreenViewport.
The ScreenViewport doesn't care
about the size of the world.
It just sets the camera up for
pixel for pixel drawing.
This is great if you need
that in particular, but
it's not super useful for most games.
Let's check out what it does.
So our checkerboard is down here on the
bottom left and it's 9 pixels tall and
16 pixels wide, and
you can hardly see it all.
Let's try another viewport that
might be better for this task.
Here we've switched over
to a stretch viewport.
StretchViewport makes the world
exactly fit the screen, but
it doesn't respect the aspect
ratio of the world, so
things might look stretched,
either horizontally or vertically.
Since our world is 16 units wide by 9
units tall, and the aspect ratio of this
is squarer than that, that means our
world gets stretched vertically or
squashed horizontally,
depends how you want to think about it.
Now we've switched
over to a FillViewport.
FillViewport does respect
the aspect ratio of the world, but
it might clip some parts of the world
in order to make that true.
For instance, this world is now
only 12 by 9, instead of 16 by 9.
The extra is offscreen to the left and
right.
A FitViewport makes sure that
the entire world is visible and
at the correct aspect ratio.
However, it does this by adding black
bars at the top and bottom or left and
right to pad out the rest of the window.
This is also called Letter Boxing.
It's what happens when you watch
wide screen movies on old TVs.
This is a great choice when the exact
size of the game world is essential,
but it can look bad on devices that
have very different aspect ratios from
what you intend.
The last viewport type
is the ExtendViewport.
The ExtendViewport also ensures that
the entire game world is visible and
at the correct aspect ratio.
It just makes the game world
bigger in the smaller dimension
in order to fill up
the rest of the space.
So if you remember from
the ScreenViewport,
we had this green apron all around.
You can see it in this version because
we're actually allowed to draw up here.
Back when we were using the FitViewport,
those black bars,
we weren't allowed to draw
anything out there at all.
When it comes to making games that
work across a whole range of devices
with different aspect ratios,
ExtendViewport is almost always the best
choice, when you can get away with it.
Remember, the ScreenViewport
makes the size of the world
match the size of the screen,
pixel for pixel.
StretchViewport makes the world fill
the screen, regardless of aspect ratio.
FillViewport also makes
the world fill the screen,
maintaining the aspect ratio but
cutting off bits of the world.
FitViewport fits the world
inside the screen,
adding black bars to pad out the extra
space to maintain the aspect ratio.
And finally, ExtendViewport makes the
short axis of the world larger to fill
the screen,
maintaining the aspect ratio.